new episodes of the into the breach
podcast digital transformation trends
for 2022 and the ga of ibm cloud
databases for mysql all on this episode
of ibm cloud now
what's up y'all my name is ian and i am
back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements from ibm
cloud
to get things started this week i wanted
to let you know that a new two-part
episode of the into the breach podcast
is now available
hosted by mitch maine of ibm x-force the
into the breach podcast brings you
perspectives and insights from a variety
of cyber security professionals to help
you better understand the underground
world of cyber crime
this new two-part episode is called lord
to the dark side the criminal hacker
journey
in part one we dive into the mind of the
criminal hacker what motivates them how
they get started who they target and
whether they deserve a second chance
part two looks at the flip side of
criminal hacks the defense
law enforcement and private security
teams work diligently to defend against
cyber threats
and they often work better together
to learn more about the into the breach
podcast and listen to the new episode
click the link in the description of
this video
next up i wanted to touch on a new
report released by ibm institute for
business value called five trends for
2022 and beyond
since the start of the pandemic the rate
of digital transformation has increased
exponentially and the report focuses on
some of the key factors that they
predict will shape technological and
business decisions in the year ahead
the report goes into all of this in much
more detail but the following five
things are some of the high level
findings
one digital transformation fueled by
cloud and ai is here to stay so don't
expect life to slow down
two fail forward to modernize business
operations
insisting on an immediate return on
innovation can lead to a fear of failure
that actually stifles creativity
three it's time for a zero trust
approach to security this is a
preventative approach that assumes
malicious actors are everywhere
four digital transformation equals
social transformation today more than
ever businesses need to consider the
social context of their actions and ai
can help businesses achieve
sustainability benchmarks
and five workplace cultures must
transform the virtualization of work has
given companies greater access to global
talent but to keep that talent companies
will need to foster cultures that place
a value on people
to check out the full ibv report and
learn more hit the link below
to wrap things up today i'm excited to
announce the general availability of ibm
cloud databases for mysql
this managed mysql offering helps your
teams focus on application and business
development by handling time-consuming
database administration tasks
ibm continuously provides fully
automated and automatic updates to the
service such as security patches and
minor version upgrades
the manage mysql database instance is
deployed as highly available across
three ibm cloud data centers in an ibm
cloud multi-zone region
to learn more about databases for mysql
hit the link below
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of ibm cloud now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics i've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video and again please don't forget
to subscribe to our channel to stay up
to date on what's going on in the cloud
now